et mon ami mon ami Jean-Luc crchman vous
savez que je l'adore je l'aime beaucoup
est avec nous pour nous faire jouer
c'est les 12 coups de lactu des
questions sachez que je remets au goût
du jour le grand concours des
chroniqueurs c'estàdire que à chaque fin
du mois pendant le pilote cétait
semaines et puis j'ai vu ça allit me
coûter une blinde donc j'ai dit pourquoi
pas le mois à chaque fin de mois Les
Chéries vous chez vous les chériis et un
chroniqueur repartira avec un magnifique
cadeau pour celui qui aura été le
meilleur celui qui aura le mieux
travaillé les chérriis ça démarre
aujourd'hui sachez que c'est un contrôle
continu donc ceux qui se
réveilleront en fin de mois et qui se
diront he ça y est la gueule en billée
et ben je vais me réveiller je vais me
mettre à bosser et ben ce sera trop tard
on leur dira avec Madame bouchardau la
conseillère principale d'éducation
toujours des VO du bouchardau ça se fait
maintenant allez première question de
jeanluc
Richman première question on va parler
bette avec quel moyens de transport
Neymar se dépisse-t-il en Arabie
Saoudite e alors attention on croirit
que c'est lui c'est pas vrai et attendez
parce que tout à l'heure il y en a on on
a fait tout ce jeu sachez-le pour une
question
vous Verz tout à l'heure on a fait tout
ça pour ça alors
répond m dir qu'est-ce que tu as onlève
la main direct déjà essaie de
parler déjà ESS quand même d'aligner de
mots et puis après tu penseras à bouger
hein
d'accord et quand on a la réponse on va
pas lever le pied il y a pas des
contorsionnistes autour de la
table il y a des gars il vont mettre le
non alors pour répondre il faut que vous
mettiez votre pied derrière la tête
merci allez bien sûr que vous levez la
main bordel en trottinette électrique
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de d'outeillage
trottinette électrique mais en or massif
tu risques pas de gagner le cadeau to il
a décidé d'être en train parce que il a
voulu être le premier footballeur écolo
non excusez-moi vous êtes ensemble en ce
moment les deux là non mais ça se
déplace tous les jours en jette on jette
en jette on jette jette on jette on
jette comme toi non en jette moi je suis
pas qu'est-ce que tu as là tu c'est quoi
là qu'est-ce qu'elle a Babé là qu'est-ce
qu'elle a Bab là un peu de sarcasme
qu'est-ce qu'elle a là qu'est-ce qu'elle
AAB elle a retrouvé sa place elle est
tout émoustillée celleci j'ai retrouvé
ma place G qui s'est plain de de Daniel
non pas du tout non non t'inquiète pas
pour l'instant on verra pour l'instant
te plains de rien plain-toi sur toute ta
meuf on
verra comme
ça me PL jamais de rien ou on s'en fout
merci avec quel moyen de transport
Neymar plile en Arabie Saoudite un avion
à 500 millions bravo
Raymond
bravo il a c'est l'avion privé qui a été
affraité pour son voyage en Arabie
Saoudite en plus de son salaire colossal
donc c'est en fait c'est il appartient
voilà saoudien et qui lui alors c'est
cet avion c'est un Boeing 747 c'est le
plus luxueux du monde il a parti en
prince saouien Al Walid bintalal euh bah
bravo lui qui et il vaudrait 500
millions d'euros faisant de lui l'avion
privé le plus cher du monde parce qu'il
l'a redesigné à l'intérieur il a enlevé
tous
lesérie son trôneou dans la des chotes
quoi ah ouais ah ouais quand
même j'adore c'est vrai qu'il a The
Voice non mais s déconner Patrick fur
qui va
arriver et donc rendez compte alors
selon le journal 20 minutes il y a dans
cet avion des chambres luxueuses dont
une suite royale il y a une table à
manger pour 14 personnes oh il y a un
trône donc au milieu de l'avion appelé
la King share ouais King ouais c'est pas
mal hein il y a deux étages ah il mesure
76 m de long et 20 m de haut que des
matériaux nobles vous pouvez regarder si
ça vous intéresse vous les chériis à 19h
188 voilà c'est un truc de fou alors
après Cristiano Ronaldo Benzema et
beaucoup d'autres c'est Neymar qui va
rejoindre un club saouien
d'adilal
d'adilal et profiter d'un salaire XXL
ouis alors il touchera donc 8,3 million
par
mois donc 2 millions par semaine 298000
€ par jour oh la vache 12400 € par heure
207 he par minute 3,44 par seconde
in un truc de fou oua les gar seconde ça
parait moins que Don tu as
raison si j'étais Neymar si on lui
demande son salaire il dit je touche 3 €
par
seconde non mais c'est tu vois un gars
qui va faire le calcul non mais c'est
vrai tu as raison c'est ça qu'il faut
faire tu sais que ça c'est très bon
c'est un journaliste je vais dire tous
les gens qui vont chez Jordan de luxe et
quand il leur demande leur salaire et
ben vous le donnez en vous le donz en
second rigoler frère je touche 0,1 € par
seconde tu casse la tête non mais c'est
vrai c'est pas mal pas mal ou il a
demandé aussi excuse-moi parce que il y
a quand même un mec qui pousse des
ralles depuis tout à l'heure là
mais non mais j'ai un gars là depuis
tout à l'heure il veut parler ça ça sort
pas en
fait
mec on dirait un C rbou à côté de moi
j'ai un mec rbou mais tu as vu à l'heure
à l'heure à l'URE redis à l'heure
combien à l'heure 1200 € par heure
presque une année de salaire en en une
heure ouais rends compte allez
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
rendor-toi s'il vous plaît amenez-lui un
plide merci ou il a demandé aussi pour
venir une maison de 25 chambres il a 5
domestiques il a eu trois voitures dont
une Lamborghini Huracan une Aston Martin
et une Bentley mal pas mal en même temps
il a sa bande de potes qu' paye pour
l'accompagner partout donc il a
besoinoup bon 2 toute une équipe de foot
avec les remplaçants je sais ou ouais
mais donc il a quoi Huracan donc Lambo
Aston Martin Aston Martin dbx je connais
c'est c'est le 44 Lamborghini Huracan et
une Bentley pas mal c'est bien après il
fait ce qu'il veut de
l'argent après moi il a raison sauf que
moi je trouve personnel c'estè SC pas
qu' des robinets en or et des trucs
comme ça ça ça me dérange pas mais
malgré tout qu'il aille en Arabie
Saoudite aujourd'hui je trouve que c'est
un PEP scè par rapport au droits des
femmes par rapport au droits LGBT par
rapport à plein de choses par exemple
les journalistes qui se font juste
lapider quand ils ont un avis contraire
je trouve que malgré tout quand on est
un joueur qui a symbolisé autant une
sorte de force comme ça dans le monde
entier alors qu'il est déjà multi multi
multimillionnaire aller dans un pays
pour encore se faire rincer ben moi je
trouve que c'est pas bien trisème pays
qui exécute le plus au monde après la
Chine et l'Iran trouve c'est pas bien
merci tout allez les cher on va passer à
la deuxème question merci mamie on
rappellera retourne au fond de la
piscine merci regardez deuxième question
attention prochaine question aux
États-Unis pourquoi un avion a-t-il dû
faire en urgence un demi-tour
mitour moi je sais alors moi je sais
parce que ça m'est arrivé je viens de
réveiller maie
excuse-moi excuse-moi je sais parce que
ça m'est arrivé arriv chien est rentr
non pas du tout non ils ont fait
demi-tour parce que le mec avait la
chiasse c'est vrai ah oua ou exactement
et je vais t'expliquer pourquoi moi
j'étais à Dakar vous étiez dans le même
avion à Dakar non pas du tout pas il
connait l'histoire non non pas du tout
mais j'ai toujours une petite gilule
qu'on appelle imodium je sais pas si on
peut le citer c'est exactement ça et
j'ai bu de l'eau avant de monter ce qui
est très dangereux de l'eau au robinet
j'avais très soif j'ai bu à Dakar en 2
minutes 26 en 2 minutes 26 la moitié
était bleue là mon corps il avait dit le
grand schtroumf hier c'était grand
schtroump sur le côté gauche je me suis
assis écoute impossible à me retenir
impossible je rentre dans les toilettes
je vois que les toilettes c'est trop
petit pourquoi parce que je suis pas en
business tu vois je suis pas en business
quand tu es en éo je rentre mon bras ça
y est je je fais arê tu peux
t'assoir c'est les mêmes toilettes en
business
en pour
fessestit excusez-moi vous êtes déjà
parti en business vous
oui les mêmes toilettes mê toilettes
d'acc AC mê mê to donc finalement j'ai
envoyé mais c'est
dire PL envoyé où sur le chariot écoute
j'ai envoyé
fort pour le fait envoyé il a dû faire
de ou c'est ça par l'odeur mais parce
qu'il était déjà en vol non non maisi le
mecoi le mec revenu faevenir par que
j'avais tellement mal que je me
liquifiaisors je dire c'est ce qui est
arrivé un passager entre Atlanta et
Barcelone ils ont été contraints de
faire demi-tour à cause d'un passager
qui aurait eu la diarrée dans tout
l'avion le pilote expliqué que ça
représent un risque biologique regardez
un truc de fou biologique
biologique vendredi dernier des
passagers d'un vol ReLION Atlanta à
Barcelone ont presque vécu l'enfer on a
un passager qui a la diarrée dans
l'avion donc ils veulent rentrer à
Atlanta 2 he seulement après son
décollage une odeur nausé abonde a
commencé à envahir l'appareil le pilote
qui a carrément invoqué un risque
biologique face à cette situation
insolite n'a donc pas eu d'autre choix
que de faire demi-tour nos équipes ont
travaillé aussi rapidement que possible
pour nettoyer en profondeur l'avion et
amené nos clients à leur destination
finale après des excuses de la
compomagnie et 8h après leur heure
d'arrivée initiale les passagers ont
finalement pu rejoindre leur destination
sans encombre et vous quel a été votre
pire racera en
[Musique]
avion c'est bon on l'a eu hein on l'a eu
on sait que mamie ne prend jamais
l'avion nai jamais pris l'avion de ma
vie j'aurais ça de pendant tout le
trajet moi ah oui donc toi tu en fait tu
donnes toujours envie toi
tu as le don de vraiment non mais c'est
vrai non mais puisquon est dessus si je
dire c'est vrai
que ça va
toi je l'entends depuis tout à l'heure
mais mais tu es devenu Isabel boss quoi
je t'entend c'est un supporteur oui
c'est ça que j'ai dit c'est qu'est-ce
qu' a un supportable un mec qui te fait
faire demi-tour juste parce que il est
malade va aux toilettes c'est un si tuas
une correspondance à prendre derrière si
tu as gens qui t'attend je préère
voyager dans le caca et pas être en
retard non non non je voyage pas il va
va au toil dans to partout
mais c'est bon alors attendez s'il vous
plaît merci des gens m merci allez alors
sachez qu'on a fait on a fait ce jeu
pour cette
question attention c'est parti pour la
question c la question in cela de la
question mon quelle star américaine a
été vu en Italie en train de se faire
miam miam le kiki sur un
bateau
[Applaudissements]
c'est
magnifique le kiki sur un bateau
extraordinaire le kiki c'est
extraordinaire oui qu'est-ce qu'est-ce
qu'elle a Ren c'est Kenny West je revois
encore la fente on lui voyait la fente
oui on
VO le sourire du plombier ça s'appelle
c'est ça j'ai
bon Kenny
West Kenny West donc il a fait il s'est
fait miam miam le kiki av venis sur une
gondole avec sa nouvelle épouse Bianca
sansoris c'est sensoris sensoris ouais
sensoris regardez non mais on va pas
[Musique]
le c'est bon c'est bon allez voilà merci
là ouais regarde le bras ouais c'est bon
c'est bon calme-toi un peu là allez
c'est bon
elle va retourner en vacances
le couple est interdit maintenant de de
voyager sur cette compagnie la compagnie
l'a interdit il sont r je crois qu'il
s'en fout total hein la vérité c'est pas
non plus voilà les chéris on va passer à
la 5e question et ça ça va vous faire
rêver
regarde c'est pas possible quelle somme
incroyable a emporté un Français la
semaine dernière àlion million ouis plus
de 100 millionro c'est combien 109
exactement qu' 109 millions c'est la
bonne réponse 109 millions point pour
mir 109 millions euh c'est le trè
chanceux en France en 2023 la loterie
européenne trème plus chanceux he 109
millions qu'est-ce que vous feriez avec
109 millions moi j'emb j'embauche des
chômeurs tu me fais chier non mais
arrête arrête ton mytho arrête arrête
ton mytho arrête un peu et ben tu vas tu
vas en avoir des chômeurs ici là tu vois
non non mais arrête Gill Verdez arrête
un peu arrête c'est insupportable non
mais tout ce que tu dis je crée une
société je les Boni je fais un gros
cadeau à Fatou avec ce qui reste j'emb
il va te rester quoi il va te rester 10
balles tu
m' c'est
vra Gill Verdez non mais Gill Verdez
qu'est tu fais déjà moi de suite
j'investis 100 millions dans
H2O 10 millions valeur sû pas s
de un peu met dans Banny j comme ça
c'est bien le groupe ban mais je
sécurise un petit peu chez toi et chez
lui tu vois et bien évid éidment Le Rest
je fait une grosse soirée avec 72 russes
et puis Çapa des hommes russes merci tu
fais ce que tu veux d'accord bien vous
prenez les 10 millions de is vous VZ pr
je prends tout
moi c'est une bonne idée million dans
banij c'est une bonne idée oui oui oui
oui oui oui ouionde on peut investir
jusqu'à enfin je veux dire on peut
investir une somme plus petite ou pas
genre si on
a cap non vous emmerdez
pas gardez-les acheter un cadeau à votre
mec
non t'emmerde pas voilà est-ce est-ce
que tu gagnes 109 millions est-ce que tu
restes à animé l'émission il reste
alors
est des belles chemises mais tu vois
rienas des belles chemises mais tu non
non mais je dire l'argent n'a jamais été
mon moteur et vous le savez
mon essence parce que cy est bénévole
ici on le sait ça vous fait rire en fait
Mo ça me fait quand vous bégayz un peu
vous Remz les épaulle c'est que vous
mentez donc c'est mytho votre truc non
non mais est-ce non mais voyez vous là
regardez vousz vous RZ les
épaules non mais l'argent l'argent c'est
pas un moteur mais c'est pas un frein
quand même pour vous
rassurez-moi je vais vous dire alors
franchement c'est j'y pense même pas je
n'y pense même pas je n'y pense même pas
vous n'y pensez pas non jamais jamais
jamais vraiment jamais vrai ou pas non
c'est
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vrai c'est c'est vrai' fout total total
l'amour et l'eau fraîche qui vous
symbolise donnez-moi de l'eau fraîche
quand même un peu Jacques qu'est-ce que
tu feris avec son9 millions je pense que
j'achète des théâtres et je produis des
gens que j'ai envie de produire ça bien
on a des problèmes producteurs de
théâtrre en ce moment donc enc c'est ça
que tuas envie de faire non j'ai pas les
109 non ok ici tu vas avir les 109
balles très vite hein bah regarde-nous
au bout d'un mois tu vasir tu vasir tu
mettras 109 € de côté il faut que ce
soit quelque chose qui qui te fasse
kiffer quoi to tu déjà du 109 dans
l'émission j'achète une île déserte
achète une le déserte une île déserte et
je mets ma famille mes amis tout ça pour
tu vois F achète déjà une île flottante
je sais pas et après une maison pour
pour pour toute ma famille enfin une
maison pour chacun pour qu'ils ai tous
un toit ah ouais franchement vous êtes
chiant ê chiant moi je veux bien la
Batmobile quoi je veux acheter la
Batmobile ah ouais c'est vrai ouais j'a
bien un superhéros je fais un truc
tu veux si tu veux j'ai un pote il a la
batte mais il a pas la
mobile Cyril j'ai vu j'ai vu la maison
d'Alex sur Instagram et il il a fait
plein de stories comme ça il a montré sa
maison c'est que décoré en superhéros
Vegas incroable c'est fou ah ouais j'ai
un Spiderman géant donc ça c'est
tuachètes la Batmobile avec 109 millions
exactement c'est fou ça et toi
excuse-moi moi une suite à l'année dans
le TR Palace enfin dans le PAL puis je
prends Raymon comme chauffeur très très
privé excuse-moi pourquoi c'est toi qui
gagn 109 millions c'est lui qui est dans
la
merde le Pau il a rien fait celu
maintenant oigation de tout me chauffer
ah ouais pas mal bon écoute vous AZ des
beau r qu'est-ce tu fais toi moi
j'envoie bouler tout le monde parce que
c'est mon rêve et ensuite je garde de TR
personnes que j'aime bien j'achète une
maison par pays dans tout le monde et je
je me balade avec mes
potes j'ai quelqu'un dans la vie
quelqu'un un jet un jet ouais n'importe
quoi je suis pas je suis pas difficile
et est-ce que tu te fais refaire la
langue ou pas la
languele c'est rien comme un Chocho
c'est rien ça passé la nu avec le grand
[Rires]
schtroump
on rigole ça va c'était pour rebonir sur
la van de Alex
gouou ça va Alex gougout allez pas
encore je tiens la route encore j'ai
envie t tap Alex gout tu fais ce que tu
veux merci mon bébé allez on va passer
tout de suite aux infos du jour avec
cette prise de
position non j'étais en train de me dire
pourquoi il demande pas ce que je fais
avec 109
millions
c'est vrai qu'est-ce que tu fais
aveclion si si Disle moi Disle moi si
j'achète des maisons aux gens que j'aime
les
proches comme ça porte malheur si tu tu
rend pas et j'essaie de faire plein de
trucs bien tu sais des des écoles où il
y a pas d'école de l'au non mais sur la
vie de ma mère au moins tu te lèves
content mais non arrête AR c'est sérieux
tu te lèves et tu sert à quelque chose
les enfants handicap desies tu es
heureux tu es heureux parce que les gens
il vont être contents de VO heure je
[__] Ave vous êtes les mecs arrêté m'
pas m'av pas demandé moi non
plus ah oui c'est vra alors moi je suis
men en fait moi je je voudrais avoir une
équipe de foot mais c'est trop cher donc
en fait je prends trois quatre sportifs
de haut niveau genre tennisman et je
leur paye tout genre
kiné professeur et tout ça et en fait
tous les voyages tous les billets
d'avion les Sping partenair et je pense
qu'ils vont devenir numéro 1 numéro 2
numéro 3 mondial et vous C avec 109
millions supplémentaires
supplémentaire
c'est mérité c'est
mérité on va se retrouver dans un
instant sans Benaï